وصفت انا لينا وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
قضيه الطاقه بالقضيه الامنيه المهمه وخلال
مؤتمر صحفي مشترك مع الرئيس الوزراء وزير
الخارجيه القطريه الشيخ محمد بن عبد
الرحمن ال ثاني في الدوحه
على ان المانيا تسعى للاتفاق على هدف
عالمي ملزم بشان التوسع في الطاقه
المتجدده
طريه الالمانيه في مجال الطاقه التي تم
اعتمادها فيما يعام عام 2022
واكدنا اهميه ذلك بالتوقيع على الاتفاقيات
اليوم توريد الغاز الطبيعي من قطر الى
المانيا سيساعدنا في تنوع مصادر الطاقه
نريد عن طريق العلاقه مع قطر ان نضمن
الاستقرار في امدادات الطاقه هناك ايضا
اهتمام مشترك بازمه المناخ ونريد ان ننتج
الهيدروجين الاخضر في المستقبل
وشددت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه على ان
قطر احرز التقدما بارزا في السنوات
الاخيره بالنسبه لحقوق العمال مفيده
بالجهود الحكوميه المبذوله في هذا الخصوص
تحدثنا عن حقوق الانسان والحريات وبشان
حقوق العمال فقد احرزت قطر تقدما واضحا
وبارزا في السنوات الاخيره وبالنظر الى
دول المنطقه فان قطر تعد قدوه في هذا
المجال ونرحب بان الحكومه مستعده للمواصله
في هذا الطريق والتعاون مع منظمه العمل
الدوليه جوهري في هذا السياق ونعرف ان
الاصلاحات لا تاتي فجاه وفورا لكن بذل
الجهود والتوجيه السياسي مهم جدا وهذا ما
نشعر به في اوروبا بالنسبه للاستثمارات
والتعاون الاقتصادي نحتاج الى معايير دوله
القانون وبالتالي فان تحسين حقوق العمال
يستفيد منه الجميع